[Musique]
non madame vous savez comme ils
s'appellent ces instruments là n'avaient
pas des pionniers savait pas comment ça
s'appelle chessex avait fait du bruit
tout
[Applaudissements]
dès ce matin
à l'époque eric et sa mère jouée à peu
oui
parlons pas
[Musique]
la moto en faire autant les mobylettes
en font autant
donc pour vous c'est un argument non pas
du tout je crois pas je crois que on
voit beaucoup d'individus qui vont
beaucoup de personnes qui vous 24 heures
du mans et je crois que ça fait du bruit
ou 6 1
[Musique]
nous avons dû en faire je ne sais pas
moi 25 à 30 tonnes
on était assez vite de fabriquer un mime
pour pas que les japonais arrivent pour
empêcher les italiens d'arriver aussi
sur le marché français le marché belge
et on a suivi dans cette danse sillage
not to be les allemands des américains
[Musique]
comme tous les gadgets sa marque un
temps c'est sûr vous m'avez dit tout à
l'heure que vous aviez un nouveau gadget
en préparation mais il est encore secret
non absolument secret oui nous avons
peur que les japonais si on sortait que
japonais de brand touquet les gîtes à
lien ou même les allemands
alors qu'est ce que vous en avez fait ce
gadget pour l'instant qui existe qui a
glissé les dangers un coffre au secret
[Musique]